There’s strange pulses of energy coming
from deep space and astronomers are trying
to understand what they mean...
Could it be aliens or maybe just your microwave
oven?
Hello!
I’m Ian O’Neill, space producer at Discovery
News, and I’m really excited to be shooting
here at the YouTube Space in in my hometown
of LA!
Now, if you’re a regular reader of my articles,
you’ll know that I LOVE a good space mystery.
Not only does the word “mystery” get me
excited, it also makes web traffic soar like
hitting the jackpot on a Vegas slot machine,
so before pulling the “alien card” I like
to examine every possibility before jumping
to THAT conclusion.
And fortunately, astronomers are of the same
mindset -- detecting a mysterious signal from
the depths of space isn’t necessarily a
strange thing; it’s just that with all the
awesome possibilities the universe contains,
a mysterious signal just means we’ve found
something new and exotic.
So, that brings me to fast radio bursts, or
FRBs.
FRBs are very rapid radio pulses that have
been detected at random locations in the cosmos
at random times.
They are transient flashes lasting microseconds
that appear to originate beyond our galaxy.
By pure luck, should a radio telescope be
pointing directly at one, we can measure its
properties.
Since 2001 only a dozen of these FRBs have
been detected, mainly by the Parkes Observatory
in Australia, but astronomers reckon that,
if we could observe the entire radio sky at
the same time, we could detect thousands of
these flashes every day.
Astronomers have to be careful of interpreting
the source of FRBs as there are many terrestrial
sources of interference that can mess with
your data.
FRBs that originate from human activity or
weather events are known as PERYTONS, and
in an effort to understand the origin of perytons,
the scientists at Parkes decided to set up
a real-time radio interference detector at
the observatory.
During an observation run in January, the
telescope detected three peryton events and
these events matched detections by the real-time
interference detector.
This was a sure sign that the radio pulses
were not extraterrestrial in nature.
And the mystery soon evaporated when they
realized that these perytons were actually
being generated by a microwave door being
opened prematurely in the kitchen at the observatory.
This may sound like a silly investigation,
but it is quite the opposite -- by tracking
down sources of interference, astronomers
can better shield their sensitive radio antennae
against them and remove their signatures from
deep space observing campaigns.
But also, it proves that the FRBs of extragalactic
origin are real signals from millions of light-years
away and yet we STILL HAVE NO CLUE what they
are!
Of course the tabloid press still thinks the
signals are caused by aliens, but that’s
hardly surprising.
When mysterious regular radio pulses were
detected in 1967, astronomers named the flashing
object “LGM-1” -- where LGM stands for
“Little Green Men” after the idea that
the pulses may be created by an alien civilization.
The signal was actually being caused by a
rapidly spinning neutron star and became the
first ever detection of a pulsar.
We have now detected thousands.
FRBs are just as mysterious as those Little
Green Men were in 1967, but there are some
exciting ideas as what they could be.
Generated over a region hundreds of miles
wide in extra-galactic locations, FRBs must
be extremely energetic.
That MIGHT suggest they are being triggered
by black hole collisions.
Or they MIGHT be generated by evaporating
black holes, hinting at a quantum origin of
gravity.
Or they MIGHT be created by ... something
entirely different.
So the next time you hear about mysterious
signals from outer space, it doesn’t necessarily
mean aliens are behind it.
Unless, of course, those aliens are using
microwave ovens to heat up last night’s
take-out.
Sorry to burst your bubble - are you disappointed
in this finding or does it fascinate you?
Let us know in the comments below and subscribe
to DNews for more science every day of the
week.